terrassé par la colline des silos et
choisit courait comme des rats au
foisonnement la conduite du grand
gendarme le cagibi qui pensaient est un
menu égayer un menu est chaud le château
vous en faisait crever pas mal
s'il voulait continuer à ce jeu-là il
allait falloir qu'ils se reproduisent en
léger by malheureusement n'avait jamais
réfléchi à la question
le professeur gimmick ont dit qu'il
fallait pondre des oeufs mais comme
l'egypte y avait de bien trop petites
pattes c'est cela on ne pouvait pas les
couvées ça donne est affreuse choses
lamentables qu'on n'ose à peine vous
montrer et que nous verrons dans une
autre émission nous l'egypte ils
décidèrent qu'il prendrait des oeufs
plat d'à côté c'était pratiquons les
pouvait facilement et même vous pouvez
faire couvrir par un lourd mais d'un
autre côté c'était pas si astuces ucsa
parce que le gie bixi sortait
obligatoirement il était plat et se jbe
plat à son tour pour modèle un oeuf plat
mais alors beaucoup plus plat cela va de
soi
la fois d'après le fait d'être encore
plus extra plat etc etc de sorte qu est
la deuxième ou troisième génération la
famille jbe voilà ce qu'il veut rester
une ridicule pelures d'oignon et s'était
pas tout un oeuf donnait soit agi vite
face soit 1 gbit profil mais jamais les
deux à la fois alors les malheureuses
bêtes et ray pour retrouver qui ça fasse
si son profil essayer de faire un jb
complet mais mia n'est jamais vous
pensez
sans compter que ces moitiés de gy be la
moitié du temps on les voyait pas
c'était pas pratique pour faire de la
télévision
ça continue comme ça on pourrait pas
renouveler leur contrat ou et les jours
des jb étaient comptés j'en ai bien peu
chers téléspectateurs